the hopes were high a recovery a
breakthrough was expected for this year
instead the word economy is just
plodding along with positive stimulus
not really in sight right now Yahoo
moobot from Deutsche Bank research is
here with me the latest divx that you
and your colleagues came up with is also
pointing into that direction the work of
the economy is more let more or less
flat lining right the DVI axis flat so
it moves sideways now for four months
there's a whole year 2015 the main
reason for this development was the
weakness of China and the United States
in particular the United States nearly
stagnated we had no crows rate in the
first quarter and we hadn't flat
development and we expected much
stronger crows and now we have some
lower hopeful year developments we
expect lower and full year crows rates
for the United States but also for China
and our world crows should be around to
three percent and not clearly above
three percent as expected at the start
of the year economies talk about a phase
of weakness that the world economy is
going through right now phase means that
the current state is just a temporary
one and the face will be over anytime
soon is that realistic in particular the
United States it's realistic I think the
underlying strength of the United States
if you look at the labor market and the
housing market is still very strong and
we also see a very extol expansionary
monetary policy so now we just cast the
first rate hikes of the fête but overall
the Fed still buys mortgage-backed
securities and we only talk about if the
first few rate hike so interest rates
should remain low and should be positive
for the whole economy mm-hmm the
International Monetary Fund states that
the emerging markets are one of the main
problems for the world economy right now
they are underperforming they are not
really tapping their full potential
right now how big is our problem problem
is that really for the
economy well it's a problem because the
weight of the emerging market is now
roughly fifty percent of global growth
so if there's a weakness in many
countries this directly translates into
lower global crows and we see in
particular in China and Russia and
impress seal that the latest indicators
were relatively weak with sanctions and
the weak economic development in Russia
we see that press press eel is copying
with a corruption and with an economic
decline and also in China we have a
sluggish growth and a lot of problems
with respect to wealth and high house
prices so these are major concerns for
the global economy going on another much
debated topic are the investments in the
industrial countries that have declined
in the past months is that contributing
to that flat world economy right now
well that's to be doing relative to the
high growth rates pre-financial crisis
but now given the high depth levels in
many countries in the private as well as
the public sector and given the
technological shift which is where when
less investment is necessary for the
digital revolution it's clear that
investments are less necessary to kind
of generate crows and to bring the
country in a more stable position mm-hmm
thank you so much mr. move it so far
growth and recovery are of course the
big targets also for a big economies
such as Germany but that of course is
only possible if companies can produce
and deliver unhampered Lee however
strikes here in Germany make that quite
difficult from time to time right now
there's a several day a multi-day rail
strike here in Germany with what
economic consequences that is the
question we want to dedicate to in our
focus interview Germany a strike nation
you can see that online at DW de /
english / made in germany